hello everyone and welcome to Round
seven of the 1960 World Chess
Championship match between Michael Tao
and Mikhail Botvinnik now I hope you all
enjoyed Game six
that was one of the greatest games ever
played in the World Chess Championship
match especially the Knight f4 move but
as everyone else in the world was busy
analyzing that move towel and Alexander
Koblenz had other plans as after Game
six it was a rest day so they had a very
busy day and they had to figure out how
to count Robotnik's caro-kann defense in
game 7 as according to the previous
games were bought in he had the black
pieces he will not choose any other
opening but the caro-kann defense and if
you've seen my video on Game five then
you you've noticed that after botanique
played east six in the caro-kann defense
tal started considering a bit of
sacrifice on e6 and he didn't find any
good continuations for white during the
game but he did find some after the game
in his home preparation but Botvinnik
also as he is a master of home
preparation thought thought about the
bishop sacrifice on e6 and he decided to
choose a different line of defense for
caro-kann so let's see this game and
although tal was two points up in the
match so far this is game 7 he says that
he still can't afford to play safe as
it's like impossible to draw all the
games to the end to just a win by his
two point lead he will still have to
create some interesting games so tall of
course opens with E for c6 of course by
Botvinnik the caro-kann defense d4 d5
Knight to c3 D capers on e4 Knight
captures on e4 Bishop to f5 Knight to g3
everything is the same as in game 5
Bishop to g6 and nice to e2 like in game
5 tau is preparing Knight to f4 but here
instead of e6000 ik started thinking and
the tal says he was thinking for about 6
minutes and after 6 minutes he played
Knight to d7 Knight to d7 is an idea in
the car Condit
black wants to push he 5 immediately he
doesn't want to go east 6 and go for the
standard caro-kann setup and
now if tall would continue Knight to a4
then II five pretty much solves all of
his problems
now you capture capture capture capture
you can capture the bishop and after
Bishop to e3 it's a pretty pretty decent
position for black and both were white
but definitely a position between it
would favor his pawn structure is a bit
ruined here but he does have an open H
file for the rook so a pretty evil
position
so after this Knight to d7 move tally
immediately goes for h4 he's waiting
with Knight to f4 h6 you can't allow
white to push h5 and only now Knight to
f4 here botanique he can't push a five
like I've shown in the previous
variation because now Knight captures an
g6 would force black to capture with the
f1 so Bishop to h7 and now Bishop to c4
and botany who goes for a5 as this is
the whole idea of point nine 37 to push
a e5 early Queen to e2 and this Queen to
e to tell thought that entering the
endgame would be much favorable for him
but later after this game tal only
realized that he already played this
game a couple of years ago and that he
came to the conclusion that black is
completely fine after exchange in
Queensland going for the end game but
playing this game he didn't know this
and it's a good thing he didn't other
than this Queen to e2 move an idea is
also nice to d3 but that was all only
considered this after the game was
played with the idea of sacrificing up
upon here but for some rapid development
but okay after E 5 Queen to e2 and now
we have Queen to e7 tal captures we have
Queen captures and now Bishop to e3 and
now tallies definitely had in
development and the botanique has to be
very careful what you do here he can't
Castle queenside although that would be
very nice for black because the f7 point
is hanging so here in botanic forces the
exchange of Queen's Bishop to c5 we have
Bishop captures
Queen captures with check King captures
Knight captures on c5 and now rook H to
e1
tal says that
botanique played Queen captures and he
captured with the king that maybe it was
better capturing with the night as the
night isn't really doing a lot of things
here on g3 and this Bishop is
controlling it very nicely but he says
tal says he want he wanted to play a
provocative move so he played King kept
rosani to Knight to f6 and now b4 Knight
c-37 and now King to f1 would check King
to f8 and now Russia back to b3 and here
both eunuch plays g5 and Tao says this
is an excellent move he really enjoyed
this move by Botnick as it gets rid of
towels active night on f4 also he's
preparing to bring the king over to g7
and then activate both of the rooks so
hg after sun g5 h capture sun g5 and
here top plate Knight to h3 and now one
might think tall has a weird looking
night here because the bishop is
controlling it very nicely and he has
another knight on h3 what is this Knight
doing on h3 well for one it's preventing
black four from pushing g4 as the pony's
attacked you can't put g4 if g4 9 f4 and
now this Knight on f4 is there forever
there is nothing black can do to get rid
of it he's controlling all of these very
nice squares so this would be a big
positional blunder by bought tunic so
instead after Knight to h3 botanic plays
rook to g8 and now protecting his g5
pawn and here we have rook to d1 here
when top played rook to d1 he realized
that he really doesn't have any
advantage as a white in this position
but he doesn't want to allow rook to e8
exchanging brooks and then drawing the
game so early on as it's only moved 20
and he does have the white pieces so
rook to d1 and since now he did play
rook to d1 now bow to make plays a 5 and
a 5 is a is a very nice move because now
if you if you want to play something
like a 3 you get a 4 this bishop has
nowhere to go we have to remove the
bishop the bishop a - you lose the c2
pawn
so after this a5 move of course be
captures an a5 this was forced route
captures an a5 and here top plays
a brilliant move he plays rook to d6 and
it's it's not a move that actually gives
a yd advantage or anything but it's just
a beautiful paralysing now that the
tallboy worked to d6
you can see that these two knights are
covering each other
this Knight is protecting this night and
this Knight is protecting this night so
neither of the Knights can move as if
you move one night you lose the other
so King to e7 by botanique protecting
the Knights and attacking the rook and
now rook a to d1 and if nothing tall
simply doubled up rooks on the D file so
as a small victory if even if not a real
one rook to e5 it to bot you need some
time to decide to go for this move but
tal agrees with him that it's it's the
correct move it the rock is very active
and e5 and you know move that also was
able you know black could have
considered was night to c5 simply
attacking the bishop and then maybe
going for the C to pawn but after night
c5 rook to d2 black doesn't really
achieve anything here so okay rook to e5
and now we have Knights to h5 and this
is a weird move just playing Knight to
h5 of course if botnik captures it then
double capture on d7 and this is a idea
this is the idea of the quote above the
board toss him to play this night to h5
with the idea of exchanging his stupid
night and g3 for botanics active knight
on f6 so basically that's that's the
only idea tall hat here and here if you
play there is also some tactics involved
here but only if botnik like makes a
blunder
for example even b5 that's not a blunder
but what we need but Finnick also saw
that if he played something like this
dental would have the option of playing
rook captures on d7 and after Knight
captures rook captures on d7 King
captures Knight to f6 check and after
the King moves you lose the bishop on h7
but here it wouldn't be possible because
there is no way for this night to get
back into the game so even a move like
b5 who was not a blunder but the Botany
that doesn't want to get tangled in
talus tactics and
he immediately gets rid of this idea he
plays Bishop to g6 and Bishop to g6
although it prevents an idea like that
which wasn't really a threat both eunuch
just saw ghosts but you know it's
interesting that it can happen even to a
player like Botvinnik
in a World Chess Championship game so
this does eliminate the threat of
actually at some point capturing the
bishop on h7 but the bishop on h7 was
also guarding the rook on g8 so this
pretty much I mean this is amazing
because the bottom Enoch was wasn't he
played a move to not allow tall to play
a certain tactic and because he played
it he directly allowed too tall to play
this tactic so tall just played rook
captures on d7 night captures rook
captures King captures Knight to f6
check for King the king and the rook and
g8 King moves Knight captures on g8 and
now you can see that tall has two
knights although they are two very
poorly placed Knights for the rook but
they are two pieces for the rook so look
to c5 immediately but when he goes to
win some material as both the bishop and
rook are attacking the c2 one knife to
h6 style wants to activate his Knights
as soon as possible
now of course if Bishop Tadros on c2
then tauten capture on f7 which check so
first f6 Knight to g4 now attacking the
f6 pawn and here botanic played Bishop
captures and c2 and tall doesn't agree
with Bishop captures on c2 tall things
that f5 would give black more chances to
hold this position simply you know
you're kicking this night away you're
not allowing him to capture on f6 but
okay Bishop captures on c2
Knight captures on f6 and now Bishop
captures on b3 and now you see this
possibility of Knight to e4 checking the
king forking the rook the bishop is
still attacked
well if you play this you would you
would definitely not win this game you
would probably even lose it because if
you played this checking the King
forking the rook the King moves now
captured the rook and now if black
captures the white knight on c5 then you
capture the bishop by
the problem is Bishop to c4 check King
moves now to capture Knight captures and
g5 Bishop captures on a2 and you have to
passed pawns on the Queen side White has
to passed pawns on the Kings side but
you do have a bishop against tonight and
the place on both sides of the board so
if anyone can win this game is black but
you know even if even if it would be a
draw it would be a terrible mistake in
this position to play Knight to e4 check
which tall doesn't top is a capture some
b3 still keeping his tonight for the
rook we have rook to b5 attacking the b3
pawn Knight captures on g5 and now rook
a person b3 and here
tal says he has to he'll do connected
passed pawns the bottom he has to
connect at passed pawns but his pawns
are escorted by a lonely rook and stahl
says that he has two fast horses for the
race
so f4 tally immediately starts pushing
his passed pawn rook the b1 check King
he to rope the B to check King f3 Ruby
three check King g4 and now rook to be
two of course attacking the g2 pawn g3
and now b5 botanique also starts pushing
his past pawn but tal has an extra tempo
up his sleeve
Knight to e4 check now this comes where
the tempo the King has to move and now
f5 clearing the way for the past F pawn
the knight is also controlling the F 2
square so the rook can't go behind the
past pawn before we have f6 and now
comes rock - a - f 7 and now rook to e8
stopping pawn from promoting itself tal
plays Knight to h7 and this is a very
interesting move because you can't
capture this knight on e4 now if you
capture it you get nice to have 6 check
King has to move and now you get night
to e8
simply blocking this rook it'll rook has
to capture it you bring your queen or if
like there's nothing you simply play f8
and promote to a queen so I very nice
tactic night - h7 so botanique plays b3
starts pushing his own past pawn and
here you can't promote to a queen
immediately if you do this black simply
black simply captures that after you
capture it
I mean
the BT pawn is unstoppable so after this
beat remove top plays Knight the d2 we
have b2 and this is well there were a
lot of nice moments in the game but this
is a critical moment in the endgame here
you have only one move that wins the
game for towel so you're tall pause the
video try to defeat Mikhail Botvinnik
also a very nice position to study your
endgame skills you always say you want
to study the endgame so here's your
chance so for those of you who found the
move congratulations you are an
excellent player and for those of you
who maybe didn't want to waste too much
time and just want to enjoy the show in
this position top plate King to f3 and
this is the only winning move since you
have to bring the King over to prevent
both C and B pawn so the king will at
some point come to see - and you
definitely can't allow black to reach
all the way to d3 if you loud like to
reach d3 you can no longer win this game
so came to the fore body Nick still
tries to reach d3 but King to e2 not
allowing him c5 but when it starts
pushing his other passed pawn now it's
time to promote to a queen but now the
two knights will have excellent
cooperation rook captures Knight
captures c4 now
Knight to e6 check we have King to d5
Knight to f4 check King d4 and now
Knight the b1 and here after playing
Knight to be 1 Mikhail Botvinnik
resigned to the game and game 7 also
went to Mikhail tal so now after after
seven games stall is in the lead three
points why did he resign it seems like
if Botanic wood were to push c3 here
that he's actually winning the game
because you know if you capture it if
you capture with the 19 captors then you
can promote the b-pawn but this was the
whole point of tal bringing his King all
the way here now if c3 is played King to
be won and the black doesn't have a move
King III simply play King to c2 and
after and after King to f3
hoping to win the Jeep on simply Knight
to e2 and now black really doesn't have
a move if he captures the knight then he
can no longer
the best porn and if he doesn't do
anything what we'll simply capture both
pawns and then escort his passport up
the board so yeah after night the b1 a
wonderful move to end the game and move
52 that was Game seven 12 versus
Botvinnik 1960 match I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon with
another interesting game thank you